now that was all bad enough
but as i said it has been usurped beaten
in the contest for most deranged public
school incident this week by events at
buena vista middle school in california
the daily wire has the story says in
october a shocking report claimed that
teachers at
a salinas california middle school
secretly recruited students into a
pro-lgbt club
just got disguised as a gender equality
club without their parents knowing
in the club teachers reportedly
indoctrinated the pupils into accepting
progressive teachings on sexuality and
transgender ideology even going so far
as to coach students into changing their
gender while advising them on how to
hide their new identity from their
parents
at least one couple who said they were
parents of a student claimed they were
called into buena vista middle school
where a teacher told them that their 12
year old daughter was now a boy
according to the father when they
refused to use the daughter's preferred
pronouns the teacher called the public
safety officer to the meeting
on tuesday night they were able to
address these teachers for the first
time at a local school board meeting the
unnamed mother excoriated the teachers
for allegedly changing her daughter's
name using different gender pronouns and
altering key school accounts without her
knowledge while helping the daughter
transition into a boy
now we have some of that speech
from the mother whose name actually is
jessica
by the way and let's listen to that
let these teachers come in and act as if
they have nothing
wrong they've done nothing wrong a
mistake
how long of a mistake how many mistakes
are we going to take before my child
almost lost her life they didn't tell me
that my child was suicidal
you allowed these teachers to open their
classrooms teaching predatorial
information to a young child a mindful
child that doesn't even know how to
comprehend it all
how do you not know what was going on on
your own campuses
did you think that no parent would ever
come forward you will not quiet me today
i will stand here today and protect my
child along with every other child who
has not come forward yet
do you do do they have psychiatry
degrees that i was unaware of because i
didn't hire them okay i did not hire
them to sit there and nitpick my child's
brain
you took away my ability to parent my
child
even before i had any knowledge
i didn't even get to show support you
asked for support i didn't get a chance
you planted sneeze miss caldera and miss
barack mr brook and you miss pagarin
your job was to educate my child in math
science english etc do your job and let
me do mine now we're so used to hearing
uh performative outrage that it can be
jarring almost to hear true righteous
outrage but that's what that sounds like
because that was no performance this was
desperation and fury from a mother who
was trying to rescue her daughter
the epoch times has a little more on
this story it says two teachers at buena
vista middle school in salinas were
recorded coaching other teachers to
conceal the nature of lgbtq clubs from
parents at a sold-out california
teachers association conference held in
palm springs california from october
29th to october 31st
so this was before so this is backing up
a little bit this is before the incident
with the daughter before this meeting
which was this week
uh so going back in october there was a
meeting of teachers where they were
where they were being coached on how
exactly to
coach the kids
the cta event was billed as the 2021
lgbtq plus issues conference beyond the
binary identity and imagining
possibilities
jessica conan who's the mother
claims that one of her daughter's
teachers then coaxed her daughter to
join a lunch hour equality club and
began affirming her daughter as
transgender near the end of sixth grade
conan's daughter told her she might be
bisexual and by the middle of seventh
grade conan was called to the school for
this meeting with her daughter a teacher
and the school principal the teacher
told conan her daughter was transfluid
jessica said i sat across the table and
i was crying i was trying to absorb
everything they kept looking at me
angrily because i kept saying she
and that it was going to take me time to
process everything
she said i was very confused i was very
upset i was blindsided completely
blindsided the teacher accused conan of
not being emotionally supportive of her
daughter who was to be called by a new
name and male pronouns would be using
the unisex restroom at school
i felt she completely coached my child
conan said
so this is the the school
informing the parents
that their child has a brand new
identity which the school has
assisted helpfully assisted the child in
informing
your child that you thought you knew is
dead
and now you have a son and here's his
name this is what you're going to call
him
that's what the school's doing
now
mrs conan says that she feels like her
daughter was coached and she was coached
but i think coaching is is not exactly
the right word because coaching is what
you do on the sidelines of a football
game coaching happens in workplaces
parents coach their children
but when strange adults impose their
sexual ideas onto pubescent children
and attempt to coax them into a certain
sexual lifestyle
that's what we call grooming
this mother sounds utterly traumatized
because she is traumatized her daughter
is a sexual abuse victim
and she had to sit in the room with her
daughter's sexual abusers
and be lectured by them
imagine that
your child is sexually abused and then
you get called into a meeting
with your child's abusers
and they lecture you and then call the
police on you
her daughter of course is even more
traumatized as the primary victim here
and the one whose mind and life and
self-perception are at stake
so this is grooming this is sexual abuse
and it's done by degenerate perverts
many of whom get a sexual thrill out of
having these intensely sexual
conversations with children and we know
that's the case but because the public
school system as i've pointed out many
times is utterly littered with sex
predators
it's probably time we stop pretending
that the explosion of sex assault and
pedophilia in the school system is
somehow disconnected from this sort of
psychological grooming
but there's another word that
could be used too i think
and that is abduction
so the schools here are are not only
grooming children and abusing them but
also committing a form of kidnapping
they are in a very real sense trying to
steal children away from their parents
they want to abduct the child the one
that you know
your child the one you raised and
replace him with somebody else
i mean they're literally trying to make
a new child
with a new name and everything
it's not so much the traditional form of
kidnapping as it is a kind of invasion
of the body snatchers technique
but the effect is much the same
and morally speaking the kidnappers and
abusers in the school system aren't much
different from the predator in a van
prowling the neighborhood
[Music]
they deserve to be treated with the same
contempt and
hostility and we have to protect our
children from them just the same
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends